so nice to be here tell you a little
about myself played sports growing up I
started at quarterback on our high
school football teams of sophomore and
it was rough we lost one football game
that season 84 to nothing my mom was
like Michael what did you learn I was
like I learned that seven times 12
equals 84 this press conference is over
so then I had to get a job when I was in
high school because I wasn't gonna go
pro right away my first job ever I
worked at a graveyard I was a graveyard
weed whacker to be specific that's not
what I wanted to tell people right away
Michael what do you do I got a yard work
for really old people you know people
that can't go out there and do it on
their own then I went to college I was
an English major when I was in college
because I didn't wanna have to worry
about getting job interviews
my English major didn't land me any jobs
but it did help me spell check my
rejection letters sometimes people judge
you just off your major like all your an
English major all English majors I know
are arrogant and pretentious on my wall
I don't even know what those words mean
all my friends from school are starting
up kids I remember when I was a little
kid my parents are very strict
especially when it came to going to bed
at night my mom always made me go back
really early so I'd make her tell me a
story so I could stay up later but it
would never be like a great story and
started out good she got you wanting her
story okay just like once there was a
little boy all right it's pretty good
for the current demographic and his name
was Michael oh my god that's my name
what are the chances but then like three
minutes in it wouldn't even be a good
story
any what she should be like in here two
brothers their names her Patrick and
Brian and they're always really nice to
him like that's enough you can leave
that's not even a story you're just
looking at me and then talking that's a
documentary it's not the genre I
requested when I'm a parent I'm gonna
tell my kid awesome stories and if he
falls asleep I'll wake him up because
that's rude
[Applause]
yeah yeah I like visiting my parents
whenever I get a chance to live near
Chicago I uh yeah yep I I got lot of
parking tickets in density and the cool
thing about Chicago parking tickets is
on the ticket it'll list all the
different kind of parking tickets you
can get and how much they all cost so
you can compare like I learned it's $50
cheaper sometimes apart on the sidewalk
how do they figure out that pricing
system there's like you parked in front
of the fire hydrant
it's dangerous $100 work on the sidewalk
hilarious $50 I met my girlfriend in
Chicago I have a girlfriend she's very
sensitive or critical I'm not sure which
if I'm quiet for a little bit she'll
just be like what are you thinking I'm
not gonna tell you that that's why I
didn't say it out loud
that's how thinking works I think things
and the things I want to say I say and
then the things that I think will hurt
your feelings I don't say
we can't just ask I'm not gonna lose you
because you got to know me better
I'm Catholic I don't believe in thoughts
before marriage I was getting nervous
when she asks like I'm being recorded
forever you know like like that moment
at a wedding when the camera guy gets in
your face like what do you want to tell
the bride and groom prove us wrong
[Applause]
you